Rav je vais terminer par Jam tout à
l'heure par qu' il va nous expliquer
vraiment ce qui peut arriver avec cette
cette décision Stéphan ravier vous vous
êtes bien sûr pour oui j'ai j'ai j'ai
voté dès
demain la suppression de la me l'aide
médicale d'État quelques
chiffres selon une étude d'octobre 2023
mesdames et messieurs 63 % des Français
ont déjà renoncé à se soigner c'est
quasiment de sur TR le gouvernement a
demandé 600 millions d'euros d'économie
aux hôpitaux la prise en charge des
soins dentaires par la CQ est passé de
70 à 60 % en octobre et au cours de ces
20 dernières années on a supprimé 100000
lit d'hôpitaux expliquant aux Français
imposant aux Français cette vision
économique que nous n'avions plus les
moyens que l'hôpital était àagonie qu'il
fallait se serrer la ceinture et dans le
même temps dans le même temps l'on a
créé en 2000 l'aide médicale d'État et
qui aujourd'hui atteint des sommets avec
dans l'aide médicale d'État je rappelle
que c'est une une une la prise en charge
médicale qui qui est réservé à des
étrangers clandestin oui parce que
j'entends sans papier on pourrait penser
que c'est cette foutue administration
française qui a oublié de donner des
papiers ce sont des clandestins ce sont
des hors la loi et bien ils sont pris
intégralement en charge et ça nous coûte
1illard2 million d'euros aujourd'hui il
y a eu 20000 bénéficiaires de plus en 6
mois donc on voit bien que ça constitue
un appel d'air et ça leur est réservé il
ne cotise rien et il perçoivent tout
imaginez les téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent ce soir mais ils doivent être
en folie et je les comprends il y a là
une véritable injustice sociale et c'est
un encouragement à l'illég à
l'illégalité c'est que vous pénétrez en
France vous avez quel de façon illégale
vous avez 95 % de chance d'y rester
puisque les otf ne sont pas ne sont pas
appliqués et en plus on vous on vous
réserve une aide médicale qui n'est pas
accordé aux Français qui eux contribuent
travaillent toute leur vie et à qui on
dérembbourse les le prix des mutuels
explose les médicaments sont
dérembboursés comment voulez-vous que ça
soit entendable par les Français c'est
donc une mesure de justice nationale
toute la séquence les pancartes s'il
vous plaît alors donc pour vous donc
c'est vous l'avez dit c'était cétait une
urgence pour vous bien sûr c'est une
urgence dans la situation dans laquelle
se trouvent des millions de le
compatriotes il y a 10 millions de
pauvres dans ce pays alors il y a bien
sûr les français puisque notre système
économique ultralibérale en fabrique
chaque jour un peu plus mais
manifestement on en a pas assez on en
importe des des pauvres mais enfin en
tout cas il y a 10 millions de pauvres
dans notre pays je crois que moi en tant
que Français et en tant que
parlementaire français il est de mon
devoir de réserver les les avantages
sociaux à nos compatriotes d'autant que
nous sommes à l'os le peu de financement
que nous avons encore il doit être
réservé à nos nationaux
alorsche je me tourne vers Jamil parce
que c'est quand même le docteur donc lui
il va nous dire euh déjà si principe de
réalité voilà c'est ça est-ce que c'est
possible si ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que si la France ne peut pas
accueillir toute la misère du monde elle
est tenue de prendre en charge la misère
qui est sur son sol quel qu'elle soit
c'est le principe d'égalité républicain
c'est ça deuxièmement le fait de d'avoir
recours à l'aide médicale d'urgence
d'abord cette aide médicale d'urgence on
sait pas ce qu'elle va être les il y a
pas de précision sur ce qu'elle va être
lauoui voilà mais ça c exclu non non
mais cela
exclut la la prévention c'est-à-dire que
vous avez une jeune femme une migrante
qui arrive qui qui qui ne va plus avoir
droit à l'aide médicale d'État qui va se
palper le sein qui va sentir qu'elle a
une boule mais ça ne rentre pas dans le
cadre de Laamu puisque elle n'a pas mal
puisque
ce n'est pas une maladie chronique et
donc elle ne pourra pas consulter
puisqu'elle a pas les moyens de le faire
au fil des mois la tumeur va grossir
alors elle va commencer à faire mal mais
elle sera à un stade où pour plus rien
faire on ne pourra plus rien faire où ça
va coûter beaucoup plus cher avec à la
société parce que là on sera obligéence
on sera obligé dans le cadre de
l'urgence intéressant ce qu'il
dit je laiss parler à la fin mais il y a
l'idéologie et la pratique exactement
les migant pas le cancert c'est
l'idéie pr juste qu'onose des choses
renir parilleurs mig qui ne vont pas
avoir le droit de consulter puisqu'ils
n'auront pas les moyens de le faire vont
aller dans les urgences hospitalièrre et
dans les urgences hospitalières on sera
tenu on est tenu de les soigner hein ça
c'est le alors je vais vous demander le
serment on on va continuer ce ce débat
mais juste je voudrais vous montrer les
résultats du sondage ah c'est s son
incrobl ou
7 donc c'est un oui massif très très
important voilà JeanMichel ça t'tonne
pas tu voulais dire un truc oui parce
que évidemment quand vous parlez d'e
d'une femme qui concert évidemment on a
envie de la soigner enfin tous les
migrants qui arrivent les 500 je sais
pas combien les centaines de milliers
nonont pas tous le cancer là vous prenez
unement pour nous
faire aboli l'aide
médicale pour les migrants en rachoy a
aboli la l'aide médicale et bien en 2018
l'aide médicale a été rétablie parce
qu'une
étude catalane a montré une étude
catalane a montré que il y avait eu une
augmentation de 20 % de la mortalité en
3 ans chez les migrants du fait de
maladie cancéreus non prise en charge
voilà vous opposez des choses qui sont
pas opposables c'est-à-dire que vous
allez nous parler en permanence de gens
qui qui sont dans le besoin qui arrivent
et qui évidemment vous vous êtes médecin
faut
limiter la politique c'est pas forcément
de faire plaisir à tout le monde la
politique c'est de prendre des décisions
la politique c'est parfois d'avoir à dos
la moitié de la France en l'occurrence
pas vraiment a 85% de gens qui sont
d'accord malheureusement mais vous aurez
toujours raison sur cerain on est tenu
de soigner vous aurez toujours raison
mais si demain la population augmente de
12 % tous les ans là ce sont les
chiffres moi je suis allé sur les
chiffres officiels de l'aide médicale
d'urgence aujourdhui c'est 12 % de plus
chaque année comment vous même on l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure avec la
problématique des hôpitaux on n pas les
moyens on va
êre l'hôpital on va être étranglé parce
qu'on va être obligé de
soigner pas être remboursé ça va
alourdir les charges hospitalières s'il
vous plaît oui est-ce que vous pensez
que aujourd'hui en France il y a une
seule personne enfin au minimum enfin
une seule personne qui a par exemple le
qui peut faire soigner un français je
parle est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a
des gens comme ça dans cette situation
d' cancer est-ce que c'est possible ou
pas non mais ce que je dis répondz
pardon
répond ma question est très précise
question heureusement qu'on peut qu'on
soigne est-ce que vous pensez
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des gens qui ont
des maladies graves ce sont des
françaises sur le territoire français
qui a peut-être est-ce que c'est des
gens qui ne peuvent peut-être pas avoir
accès au soins non ça existe pas
so répondre M
les franis ou non français d'ailleurs l
deêtre soigné pouro le problème
qu'est-ce qui se passe problème non non
mais on disait qu'il y avait 420000
bénéficiaires de laame et il y a 900000
clandestins c'està-dire qu'il y en a
encore 500000 qui ne sont pas encore
tout à fait conscients de leurs droit
ils sont dans une situation hors la loi
je le répète ils sont dans l'illégalité
mais ils ont les droits et et notamment
celui-là qui leur est réservé et donc je
veux dire qu'il y a encore une source
quasiment inépuisable de ceux qui sont
déjà là et ceux qui viendront parce que
l'information
elle circu elle circule pardon à travers
la planète on sait qu' en ayant mis un
pied en France on va être pris en charge
pas seulement d'ailleurs pour la pour
pour l'aide médicale mais pour tout pour
le logement pour l'école pour pour
toutes sortes de de services sociaux
donc il est important de ne pas
considérer et j'entends ici ce que
j'entends au Sénat mais de votre part ça
me choque moins mais j'entends au Sénat
de la part des sénateurs de gauche que
bon ben les clandestins sont là de façon
irréversible voilà ils sont là donc on
va s'en occuper on doit s'en occuper il
n'y a jamais de leur part la volonté de
de renverser la situation c'est-à-dire
d'appliquer à ces clandestins la loi
c'est qui consiste à tout faire pour
qu'ils rentrent dans leur pays d'origine
tant que l'on on on enverra pas ce
double message et bien on on continuera
à venir en France par tous les moyens et
c'est tellement facile puisqu'il n'y a
quasiment plus de
frontières et le problème ne pourra que
se développer au détriment de nos
nationaux qui vous voulez parler je ne
comprends même pas qu'on culpabilise de
ne pas prendre en charge intégralement
des personnes qui n'ont pas le droit
d'être là alors que dans d'autres pays
ils sont sans pitié quand vous êtes même
les propres citoyens de ce pays vous ne
pouvez pas vous faire soigner si vous
n'avez pas d'argent et nous on est là à
culpabiliser bah oui aux États-Unis
attendez aux États-Unis si vous êtes
français aux États-Unis vous n'avez pas
le droit d'être là déjà ils vous foutent
dehors et vous croyez vraiment qu'ils
vont vous soigner ils en ont ren à fout
ils sont sans pitié ce sont des raisons
économiques il faut être pragmatiqu et
c'est dans le monde bah et tant mieux et
tant mieux et c'est dans le monde des
bisonours bien sûr qu'on a envie d'aider
tout le monde mais si c'est au dément
des Français qui ne peuvent pas soigner
c'est terrible je vrais je voudrais
revenir juste parce que vous avez vu le
sondage donc 87,5 12,5 ça monte encore
juste Stéphane Ravier jeis vous avez
proposé hier au Sénat aussi un
amendement visant à déchoir de la de
leur nationalité les binationaux que je
vous qui je vous cite font allégance à
une autre nation qu'est-ce que vous
vouez parler de quoi ceux qui
actuellement et avant et sans doute plus
tard manifeste leur soutien à un pays
étranger et qui hurle leur leur
détestation de la France l'actualité
récente les conduit à à à à détester et
et à crier leur haine du Juif euh c'est
ces Français qui pour moi ne sont que
des Français de papier euh lorsqu'ils
sont binationaux on devrait leur retirer
parce qu'il leur nationalité française
parce qu'ils font offense ils insultent
la France et je crois qu'il serait tout
à fait logique et légitime de le retirer
ce ne serait pas les appatries
puisqu'ils ont une autre nationalité
vous dites pour vous il faut retirer la
nationalité française pris l'exemple de
Karim Benzema oui j'ai pris l'exemple de
Karim Benzema parce qu'il a été il a il
a été ça fait deux fois qu'on parle de
Karim Benzema ici sur ce plateau en ma
présence et je l'avais qualifié c'est
pour ça que vous m'aviez invité de
français de papieràé la France il a été
il a été il a été dit que Karim Benzema
était franco-algérien oui Mo il a éé
ditétait francotunisien et c'est le
ministre de l'Intérieur lui-même qui a
mis en exerg le le je dirais le
rapprochement ou le soutien de Karim
Benzema
euh envers les fréristes les Frères
musulmans qui sont considérés comme une
une association terroriste par de par de
nombreux pays donc si si il est avéré
que que Monsieur Benzema soutient les
Frères musulmans et qu'il est avéré
qu'il a la double nationalité monsieur
Benzema comme les autres dans sa
situation et bien mériterait qu'on lui
retire sa nationalité française monsieur
ravier les Frères musulmans ne sont pas
hors la loi en France he c'est bien le
problème ils sont considérés comme
terroristes dans leur pays de naissance
et si j' dire en Égypte est-ce pouvez
RA Frères musulmans ne sont pas
interdits sur territoire français
donc que Benzema soutient les frères
musul musul ne fait pas de lui un paria
le le Hamas est issu des Frères
musulmans mais il
pas tousux qui soutiennentou Hamas par
exemple et qui sont franco quelque chose
et bien qu'il reste quelque chose mais
qu' ne soit plus Françis vous enleveriez
la nationalité à Karim Benzema
nationalité française si ce que le
Ballon d'Or
quoi Ballon d'Or il pas partag avec les
Français il Gard je
crois impô pas pay
fr
puisquelle lui a permis de former
m
pay pas
éion sansitaire monsieur moi je ne
considère pas que quelqu'un mérite d'
d'être français puisqu'il paye des
impôts ça c'était l'ancien l'Ancien
Régime y a beaucoup de Français qui ne
payent pas d'impôt parce qu'ils n'ont
pas beaucoup de ils ont des salaires
très bas on doit leur retirer le
nationalité française l'impô ne fait pas
le français pay impôts ave les sommes
astronomiques qu'il a gagné grâce à la
formation en
France en France pourquoi ilalise pas
pourquoi va aussi faut partir sur des
bases solides aussi tout ça par fait des
déclarations qu'est-ce que vous permet
de dire que Benzema déteste
la pas dit dét sub que ça il l'a pas dit
il a dit qu'il avait ch demand pourquoi
il jouit pas en équipe d'Algérie il a
dit j'ai choisi l'équipe de France pour
le côté sportif gen les résultats sont
meilleurs mais côté cœur je suis
algérien et c'est quand même pas
franisis algérien et jeou équipe de
France
arrête j'ai choisi la France pour
l'argent et le
cœurur c'est c'est le pays de mes
parents quand il l'a dit ça fait un to
pas possible
arrête a eu France Maroc je me rappelle
moiai vu Jamel Debous il était et ben il
était partagé voilà il a pas la France
mais il était parce que ça veut pas dire
qu'il aime pas la France si jamore la
France il a pas dit que son cœur était
partagé il a
dit non il a dit j'ai pris la France
pour le côté sportif et mon cœur est en
Algérie
mon tout monde pas que ça soit normal
qu' soit que son cœur soit
par mais c'est pas le Maroc qui le fait
vivre je regrette c'est pas le Maroc qui
qui lui qui a fait de Jamel de B une
superstar il
est questionussi de
Louté c'est normal qu'ilim
bien France Tunisie sur les réseau toute
es pour la France pour la Tunisie c'est
normal a pas a rien de grave je suis
désolé vous êtes ou dis je suis pour
celui sur qui j'ai misé le plus d'argent
voilà c'est tout merci en tout cas merci
c'est toujours un bonheur vraiment il
pas il est pas bon il est pas bon lui
franchement il est incroyable dites-le
qu'il est bon quand même il est bon
c'est pour ça qu'on va le garder alors
lui c'est producteur
d'émission je suis chez moi là
çaousci à toi dans un instant vous allez
voir ça cette histoire là j'ai vu ce
policier prê à parti dans une cité
marseillaise il sort son arme et T tire
en l'air que s'est-il passé ça c'est
chtiste P sal voulez rester pour ça
tiens ben écoutez j'ai que ça à faire
bon très
bien un bonheur d'être là plus c'est
Marseille donc Jam toi tu restes toi ici
tu es chez toi tu peux même t'allonger
ici je t'amène un T je t'amène un truc
tu fais un kiff à tout de suite
merci